according to a new report out of the uk
the leader of the world health
organization quote privately believes
the covid pandemic started following a
leak from a chinese laboratory
and this is of course very strange
because for years now i have been
reliably informed by the always
trustworthy establishment media that the
lab leak theory was a wild and
irresponsible
conspiracy theory
president trump is
pushing
a conspiracy theory again
that coronavirus began in a lab in china
that the five eyes these are america's
closest allies in the intelligence
community are now saying
that's not the evidence we've seen the
evidence we've seen points us to animal
to human transmission
someone saying
that the virus came from a lab the
publications say
it's
actually
something the virus has happened
naturally
it came naturally the cdc's that are
based in hubei and wuhan and also they
told me they spoke they hope to go to
the wuhan institute of virology that's a
place that's had a lot of focus on it
particularly under the former trump
administration when many senior
officials there pointed towards it
without evidence without facts to
suggest it might have been the source of
a lab leak who investigators say they've
seen no evidence of a lab leak world
health organization i should point out
down they say the lab leak theory
extremely unlikely extremely unlikely
just another conspiracy theory
except now according to this report that
cites a top government official quote
while publicly the world health
organization maintains that all
hypotheses remain on the table about the
origins of kovid the source said tedros
adonam gebrezis the director general of
the who had recently confided to a
senior european politician that the most
likely explanation was a catastrophic
accident in a laboratory in wuhan where
infections first spread in late 2019
of course
normal people have known that the lab
leak theory was likely
almost from the very beginning
that's not what's interesting about this
story it's not even all that interesting
that the who has changed its mind
the most interesting part and the most
important part of this new report is
that
while the head of the who apparently now
believes that the lab caused the
pandemic he's trying to keep that
information private
the reason is that the who which is the
institutional face of science with a
capital s over the last two and a half
years
is primarily a political organization
contrary to the fantasies of the libs
and the squishes
there are no neutral institutions
big institutional power means big
politics and the organizations that deny
that they have a political bent
are usually the most politically
dangerous i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from old school oh man
old school just been on the board a
number of times who said
the problem isn't that there are people
who are getting things like icons and
mascots canceled it's that there aren't
enough people willing to speak up
against them and push back that is such
a good point the the iconoclast mobs are
always going to be around they're always
going to be trying to tear things down
in healthy societies you've got people
who will say no here is why it's good to
have a george washington mascot here is
why it's good to wave the american flag
here's why we're going to stand up for
our symbols and for our civilization the
problem with our society is you've got
the barbarians at the gates they're
frankly past the gates at this point and
then all the people who are supposed to
defend the society we just shrug our
shoulders we say well you know we just
we all have to be neutral well maybe
you're right maybe it's got maybe we
shouldn't maybe we shouldn't that
american flag maybe it's not very
inclusive maybe we should they throw
their hands up in the air and they don't
defend any of the symbols they don't
offer an affirmative vision
so it's no wonder you've got these
barbarians knocking down our country
we've got to reach people when you want
to reach people you've got to check out
podium right now head on over to
podium.com slash
from supply chain issues to increased
demand on top of everything else that
business owners have to manage the
businesses that are thriving right now
are the ones that are forward thinking
podium helps your small business stay
ahead of the curve with modern messaging
tools that make it easy for your
customers to connect with your business
it is really really easy to fall into a
rut as a business owner do not let that
happen check out podium from healthcare
providers to plumbers over 100 000
businesses are texting with customers
through podium customers love the
convenience businesses love the results
you want an example one car dealer sold
a 50 000 truck in just four text
messages a jeweler sold a 5 000 ring
and coordinated curbside pickup all
through text right now see how podium
can help to grow your business watch a
demo today at
podium.com knowles that's podium.com
knowles podium
let's grow
the world health organization
that very important scientific
institution
they have really got their finger on the
pulse of what matters
right now we've just had this two year
more than two years of the coronavirus
pandemic and the world health
organization is hiding what it really
believes about the origin of the virus
to play politics with china okay great
and now we've got this monkey pox virus
that's spreading around not quite as
quickly as kovid but it's spreading
around the world and the world health
organization tedros anonymous gabrieles
i could try for 10 years i will not ever
pronounce that man's name correctly i
keep trying i have a different
pronunciation every single time that
that man and the world health
organization that he runs they're
focused on the really important things
namely
changing the name of the virus
who is also working with partners and
experts from around the world on
changing the name of monkeypox virus its
clades and the disease it causes
we will make announcements about the new
names as soon as possible thank you so
much ted rose i'm so glad the who is
devoting all of its resources to
changing the name of the virus not just
stopping the virus not to trying to
figure out why this virus is spreading
right now
not to trying to
investigate and then publicly explain
how that first virus started no no we've
got to change the name they did this
with covid they did this with covet they
discouraged the term chinese coronavirus
the wuhan virus they discouraged all of
that they then changed all of the names
you couldn't talk about the south
african variant or the indian variant no
no it was delta ami lamid and that's
great they finally
have controlled our language and that's
that's what's important isn't it
they don't want to call it monkey pox
because they say monkey pox is racist
because the virus comes from africa
which you sort of think
i didn't make that connection i i when
when i heard monkey pox i didn't view
that as racist because i don't view
black people as monkeys the world health
organization it's the liberals who are
doing they're saying wow you know this
monkey pox virus it's just people's
first thought is going to be that black
people are monkeys no that's your first
that's not my first thought what's wrong
with you people so they say that's
really important we've got to reduce
stigma
they say quote in the context of the
current global outbreak continued
reference to and nomenclature of this
virus being african is not only
inaccurate but is also discriminatory
and stigmatizing so it's not inaccurate
it's an it's a primarily african virus
the virus was first discovered in zaire
in 1970 that's where most of the
breakouts have been throughout the
history of monkey pox the the only other
place where you had big outbreaks was
west africa so yes it is african in
origin i don't think there's anything
discriminatory about referring to the
virus by the name that it's had for 50
years
and and then there's this question of
stigma
our culture wants to get rid of stigma
stigmas are really bad that we want to
get rid of shame we want to get rid of
stigma we want to get rid of anything
that's particular but stigma can be an
important thing
the stigma that most people are talking
about with with monkey pox is that it's
primarily infecting gay guys
it started at a gay fetish orgy in in
belgium and then at another gay bath
house in spain that's where the big
outbreaks have been that's what's
driving the global spread of monkey pox
but
the world health organization and the
rest of the liberal establishment
doesn't want to point out that the virus
is primarily a gay thing because they
say that's homophobic and for goodness
sakes during pride month we can't
mention something like that
but if you want to save gay people
shouldn't you mention that
don't you far from it being homophobic
don't you think it's actually quite um
homophilic
to don't you think it's quite
pro gay people living to let them know
that this is primarily a gay thing and
they should cut out the bath houses if
they want to not catch the monkey pox
virus
in the united kingdom
99
of monkey pox cases are among gay guys
99 of the people who have monkey pox
in the uk are gay guys and one percent
maybe they're being honest maybe they're
not i'm not sure but the overwhelming
overwhelming almost 100 of people who
have it
are gay guys so if you want to stop the
spread of the virus and you want to
protect people from catching it and
potentially dying shouldn't you say hey
gay guys be on high alert stop doing
that stuff that's gonna have you catch
monkey pox don't go to an orgy and
do that thing you shouldn't be doing
with a hundred guys at night if you if
you don't wanna catch monkey i've had
gay friends of mine say that that if if
you really wanted to protect the gay
community you would you would rename
monkey pox gay orgy pox and then and
because it would it would increase
stigma and it would increase stigma
specifically around
orgies in belgium and bath houses in
spain and that would be a good thing it
would be a good thing on lots and lots
of levels but the who can't do that
because it's very politically incorrect
to suggest that certain viruses will
spread more rapidly much more
almost infinitely more rapidly among the
gay community and so
they put all their focus on political
correctness and try to rename the virus
and distract from certain facts that are
crucial in trying to stop the spread
that is because it's political so
knowing that it is political we
shouldn't pretend that it's this totally
neutral scientific institution it's not
it's bankrolled in large part by china
it's politically allied to china and so
they cover up for china a lot of the
time and it's part of a broader
apparatus of liberal transnational
institutions that push all the weird
pathologies of liberalism like vocism
and political correctness and all the
rest of it
normal people are pushing back on this
kind of thing you want to talk about
orgies i don't really want to talk about
orgies but parents are pushing back on
this in schools
and libraries that parents movement that
you you've seen at school boards that
you've seen at libraries pushing back on
drag queen story hour on critical race
theory on the weird gender ideology in
elementary schools
that isn't just conservative republicans
that isn't just right wingers
that is people in the middle that is
centrists that is liberals that is
center left too and they're showing up
there was an incredible uh meeting at
the
dixon illinois library board dixon i
think that's where ronald reagan is from
actually and they show up to the library
board the library wants to have a bunch
of porn for kids in the library and the
parents show up and they say hey here is
what's going on and we don't want this
now when you want really good stuff
that your kids can watch that you can
watch that is wholesome and educational
and entertaining and supports what you
believe in you got to join the daily
wire
become a daily wire member today use
promo code knowles know w l-e-s enjoy
the exclusive benefits of being a member
you'll get 25 off with code nulls it's
really important that you do this
the daily wire is producing so much
content right now the daily wire is
really making a run for uh for
serious cultural effect and it costs a
lot of money we haven't taken capital
yet we haven't taken capital because
very often when you are raising money
and you take money so you can scale your
business it comes with all this woke
stuff that that where they force you to
sell out your message or start pushing
their crazy transgender racial whatever
stuff and so the daily wire hasn't done
this you are our capital you are the way
that we can continue to make this
content so we really need you to join
that is dailywire.com subscribe code
get 25 off
parents
in dixon illinois
are pushing back on the weird stuff at
their libraries
this one oral sex
doesn't belong in our library
not accessible to children completely
inappropriate
not okay
not okay completely inappropriate keep
this stuff out of the library
one i love that these parents are doing
it too i love that people are
videotaping it so the rest of us can see
it because i imagine that library board
doesn't want this kind of video getting
out three please send me your tips i
think it's very important on this show
that we not only you know we comment on
the crazy tick tock videos we comment on
the national news story but it's very
important to be able to bring
this kind of information out there
courage is contagious when one community
that feels bogged down by wokism sees
another small town another local
community
pushing back against it it can really
spread it can create a movement and so
send me your tips send me your videos
you can do it through my personal
website michael janelles.com you can
send it to my daily wire email i don't
care you can send it via carrier pigeon
but send me your tips from your local
community i i think i think we need to
get a little bit more activist
especially as the midterm elections are
rolling around
the parents are coming up there
they're not exactly calling for book
burnings worth pointing out by the way
that some of the greatest people in
history have supported book burnings i
know this is an unpopular view in some
corners of the right but it's true plato
supported book burnings
the apostles supported book burnings
it's in the new testament for goodness
sakes
martin luther support i'm not a you know
i'm catholic i'm not a huge martin
luther fan but martin luther supported
book burnings
there have been a lot but anyway i'm not
they're not calling for book burnings
they're just saying look you can have
whatever books you want in the library
even radical content even content i
don't agree with but not pornography not
obscenity there's never been a
protection for that ever in our whole
civilization certainly not in this
country and so no where kids are going
to be accessing this we don't want that
stuff
this is what this is why you don't go
into a library and say
back in the 1970s or 80s hey i'd like to
check out 10 playboys today and they say
well sir we don't have playboys so this
is censorship this is this is a book
burning this is no it's not you just
can't you you're not entitled to smut in
the public library and if the taxpayers
don't want to pay for smut they
shouldn't have to
we have the right to community standards
we have the right to obscenity laws
we have to remember that schools
libraries these are political
organizations
conservatives don't they don't notice
that all the time because we think well
let's get the politics out of schools
let's get the politics out of
entertainment let's but
political just means public that's all
it means the words are synonymous things
that pertain to our public life together
and so a library of course that's
political
it's funded by the taxpayers it's
pushing certain messages when the
library is promoting drag queen story
hour that is the political community
endorsing
perversion and weirdness and confusion
and a sexual ideology
when the schools are promoting this
stuff that is political the point of
public schooling is to create citizens
there is almost nothing more political
in america than public education so of
course this is going to be political the
left knows that so they wield the
politics to their own ends and the right
for a long time has just said well let's
just be neutral okay let's kick the
bible out of schools okay let's allow
the drag queen reading hour okay no of
course not then you're just giving your
whole politics to the left do not do
that sort of thing
on the topic of sex and politics
fifa the soccer organization
has just made a major ruling or i'm
sorry is proposing a major new rule on
sex and politics that would be dropping
the testosterone requirements for
men who want to compete against women
there are men
who want to who identify as women they
play in the girls league and as of now
there are certain requirements that they
not have testosterone above a certain
threshold
and thief is considering dropping this
uh the the current eligibility standard
for men who identifies women is less
than five nanomoles per liter
after at least 12 months but now they'll
say no look
look uh that
that man is a woman no matter how much
testosterone she has pumping through her
veins
and through her male anatomy and through
her just heaving hulking muscles and
through her giant manly masculine frame
she truly is a woman no matter how much
she is a man
of course of course this had to happen
mark my words i'm making a nostradamus
prediction right now if the transgender
ideology is going to advance if it's not
rejected
they're going to have to get rid of the
testosterone limits
they have to
because
either
these people the met these men really
are women or they're not
either either they're women or they're
not
they can't they there is no way to
maintain any even semblance of coherence
to for transgenderism if they say that
the the demarcator of whether a man is a
woman is the amount of testosterone he
has
they can't
because the premise of transgenderism is
my body has nothing to do with who i
really am
the premise of transgenderism is i'm a
woman trapped in a man's body
so you can't have a body requirement
to advance the transgender agenda you
have to get the body out of it
completely
either they're men or they're women and
we have to decide even fifa is a
political organization
sports leagues are political sports
athletics has had
a very close connection to patriotism to
the business of the state going all the
way back to ancient greece going all the
way back to the olympic games and in
every civilization and society since
then that's always been the case this is
why it was such a big deal when colin
kaepernick came out and protested the
american flag at the nfl
why do we wave the american flag at the
nfl why do we have the star-spangled
banner why do we have the pledge of
allegiance in some sports games because
sports always has something to do with
the political order and so colin
kaepernick pretty
pretty wisely he's not a very wise man
but he had a clever move here he said
i'm going to subvert that
so
the issue is not that we're injecting
politics into sports
as some some people held it to be the
issue is we are using sports to subvert
the traditional political order that
sports
plays a role in
and
here you've got this this sports league
making a political
decision men can be women
that's what they're saying and that's
increasingly what sports leagues have
said
we we have to decide the issue one way
or the other we the people
you know how i want to decide it i think
transgenderism is insane i don't think
it's a real category of being i think
people who consider themselves to be
transgender should be given psychiatric
help and philosophical help and
spiritual help and all sorts of help but
they should not be indulged and i think
that the people who promote this stuff
should probably be imprisoned
that's that's how i want to decide it
maybe you want to decide it differently
maybe you think transgenderism is
totally real and we need to be really
tolerant and men should be able to go
into women's bathrooms and men should be
able to play on the women's soccer team
i certainly don't care about women's
soccer i couldn't possibly care any less
about anything than women's soccer i do
care about truth i do care about reality
but
i'm just observing even outside of my
own political preferences i'm observing
the fact that
we have to decide the question
publicly
politically
for everyone
there's only going to be
one standard that we're all living under
here and you're going to see it in the
sports teams and at work and at school
and in our government and everywhere
else in society it's not enough to say
well you do you and i'll do me
you you can't do that on on basic
questions about how we're going to live
it'd be like saying that we can't have a
a national language
for right now we still have a national
language in america
the language is english that's what our
signs are printed in that's what
government forms are printed in
the libs kind of want to undo that and
have lots of different languages but
still the language of america is english
we don't each have the right to speak
our own language
if we did that if all of us spoke our
own language we wouldn't communicate
society would break down we'd just walk
up and say jubilee gobbledygu
watermelon
and you'd say huh
what and then some other person would
come out and speak a different language
and there'd be no communication you have
to
have some shared experience you have to
you have to have some things in common
if you want to have a political
community and one of those things you've
got to have in common is
what is a man what is a woman this is
why the marriage question had to be
decided politically you couldn't have
everyone just decide well it's my own
personal preference of what marriage is
no you have to you have to have that
kind of common language and the libs
know it which is why they're pushing for
their radical wrong vision on these
questions and the conservatives have
thrown their hands up in the air i heard
this during during the marriage debate
they said well look
i'm a libertarian on this question well
look i'm agnostic on this question well
look i just want to get the government
out of it
oh okay so you just you're just going to
concede it to the libs
that's all that means look i just don't
want to get political here
i oh okay
well the other guy wants to get
political and the other guy who who is
pushing a campaign that totally opposes
what you believe in then he's going to
win
because the guy who's willing to wield
political power who's going to actually
engage in political questions he is
going to be the one to succeed
that's why it's so important to lean in
here to the culture into these political
decisions that's what the daily wire is
doing right now we are not only
commenting on the culture
we are going and creating it too and
that is nowhere clearer than in the
daily wires newest movie the movie that
uncanceled gina carano terror on the
prairie you want to watch that movie
head on over right now dailywire.com
subscribe join us today that code is
knowles can wles dailywire.com
subscribe we'll be right back with a lot
more
either transgenderism is real or it is
not real that's why they've got to push
it on kids they have to push it on kids
some conservatives some squishes they
want to say well look i'm fine with
transgenderism but just not for the kids
it's not that doesn't make any sense
if transgenderism is real and you can
really be a man trapped in a woman's
body
then
for sure we should let the kids who have
that problem transition
if if some kid is really born and he's a
woman trapped in a man's body and he's
just this this woman trying desperately
to get out then of course we should
if it is the case that the medical
interventions and the chopping and the
puberty blockers and the hormone
replacement really does allow the true
woman inside of the little boy to come
out and flourish then of course we
should do that
we should do it as soon as possible
but that's not the case it's not a real
thing it's a fake thing it's a delusion
it's a fantasy and a psychological
problem that should be treated not
indulged
but if it's a fake thing
then we just shouldn't indulge it if if
the the
experience of of feeling like a woman
trapped in a man's body is just
pathological if it's just a if it's just
a mental illness then we should treat
the mental illness not chop off
functioning body parts you
you have to decide it
based on reality
based on truth
the left is making a truth claim they're
saying transgenderism is real
the conservatives up until this point
have made a preference claim
they've said well look i don't i don't
want to
adhere to that ideology but i don't want
to stop you from buying i have no right
to force my views on you and if you want
to do that that's just fine i throw my
hands up in the air i don't want to get
political i don't come on i just want to
live and let live oh okay so you're just
conceding the issue to the libs and
they're gonna push it on kids they have
to push it on on lips on the kids rather
the libs have to push it on the kids
it's confusing to say
they have to because you're you are
tacitly granting their premise and the
logical conclusion of their premise that
transgenderism is real is that you
should
allow the kids to transition
and that's what they're doing a major
transgender health organization has this
is the world
world professional association for
transgender health says it's going to
change its advice on when teenagers
should be able to get treatment also
known as poison and mutilation
because it is unethical and harmful to
withhold early treatment so the updated
advice is saying that kids should be put
on cross-sex hormones starting at 14
and the kids should have
mutilation surgery where they chop off
their genitals
starting at 15. this is sickening stuff
i actually feel nauseated reading this
information
by the way the puberty blockers start
way earlier the puberty blockers could
start at eight
and
by the age of 17
you should get full you should be able
to have full-on
genital mutilation not just the cosmetic
stuff but or semi-cosmetic stuff not
just the top surgery as it's called
where you lop off perfectly healthy
breasts but even the downstairs stuff
too
of course they're going to get away with
this because the conservatives totally
seated the ground because we're not
we're not even engaging in the debate
we're saying well i'm agnostic on
whether it's true or false even if i
think transgenderism is false i don't
want to push my political views on you
and three this isn't a place for
politics this is this should just be
decided by individuals and oh okay well
then
then the other guys are going to make
the truth claims
and the other guys are going to force
their views on everybody else including
poor little kids
and the other eyes are going to
order the culture and the politics
that's what's going to happen
and by the way the the conservatives and
the kind of squishy people who have been
saying the whole time well just let
people make their own decisions
they're now leaving these poor kids who
by definition can't make their own
decisions they're below the age of
consent they're leaving them to the
predations of these psychos and these
perverts and to be charitable charitable
about it these confused people who have
fallen under the thrall of transgender
ideology which is completely absurd and
incoherent
is that good is there anything
good or compassionate about allowing
that to happen i don't think so so
what's the solution it's a very simple
solution we just say no
we say no we've let this go way too far
transgenderism is absurd people who
think that they're transgender should be
placed in asylums or at least in
counseling and the people who promote
this stuff the doctors and the teachers
and the media people and the politicians
we should pass laws against that
of grooming little kids for this
nonsense and we should put the people
who break them in jail and that's that
and we're deciding that it's not real
anymore we're going to be charitable and
compassionate about the issue but it's
not charitable and compassionate to
mutilate little kids bodies and
sterilize them when they're 14 years old
and frankly starting even even earlier
at 8 years old there's no
whatever
train of thought
has led you to the place where you're
sterilizing little kids
you you've gone down the wrong path your
premises are wrong we need to try
something
different
if transgenderism is real which it's not
but if it's real
then this article that i just read in
time magazine is
totally normal
if transgenderism is not real
and it isn't
it is not real
we're using lots of double negatives
here then this article in time magazine
is the creepiest thing i've ever read
it's called the pain and pride of a
generation changing how it sees gender
the cover photo i'm going to block out
the poor kid's face the cover photo is
freedom a two-spirit 13-year-old posing
for a portrait for time
magazine
time magazine just spent a year
going around the country taking
photographs of sexually confused little
kids this is how they describe it they
say that
they're taking photos of gender
expansive
kids
where is chris hanson when you need him
i
i wish time magazine had called my house
said hey do you have any gender
expansive kids living with you yeah no
what's the age limit oh i don't know 13
maybe even younger yeah we want to talk
to them about their sexual desires and
identities
say uh sure come on over at five o'clock
i'd have chris hanson waiting in my
kitchen
hi time magazine yeah why don't you take
a seat right over here
oh no i wasn't gonna do nothing no no
why don't you listen time magazine why
don't you take a seat right over here
what were you planning on doing you want
to take pictures of little kids with
sexual confusion it's
super
duper
creepy we our whole society would have
known this five years ago and
exploitative and wrong and child abuse
now we celebrate it
why we celebrate it because we're
letting the libs run the politics and
the conservatives are just backing off i
bet you i i guarantee you the majority
of americans don't think that we should
be taking pictures of sexually confused
little kids
i guarantee you the majority of
americans don't think that 13 year olds
boys should be dressing up like girls
and putting stilettos on and stuff i
promise you they don't think that so why
are we letting it happen
it's not because the liberals have been
and the progressives and the leftists
and whatever term you want to use have
been so incredibly genius and they're
just they're just unstoppable it's
mostly because the conservatives
surrendered and gave up
even the drag queens get this even there
is a great viral video going around of a
drag queen an actual performing drag
queen saying guys
why the hell are you all being so
supportive of the drag queens
what in the hell has a drag queen ever
done
to make you have so much respect for
them and admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage
i have absolutely no idea
why
you would want that to influence your
child
would you want a stripper or a porn star
to influence your child
it makes no sense at all
a drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults
there is a lot of filth that goes on a
lot of sexual stuff that goes on and
backstage there's a lot of nudity sex
and drugs
okay and honestly you're not doing the
gay community any favors in fact you're
hurting us okay we have already had a
reputation of being pedophiles and being
perverts and deviants we don't need you
to bring your children around so you
keep your kids at home
or take them to disneyland or take them
to chuck e cheese
preach preach drag queen you're telling
it like it is i love that line take him
to chuck e cheese what's wrong with you
people what what has a drag queen ever
done
to make you have so much respect for us
you think oh right it was amazing how
quickly the the libs did this they
blurred all the lines
they said gay guys
and we need to tolerate gay guys and by
tolerating gay guys we need to embrace
transgenderism for some reason i don't
really quite know how that necessarily
follows and then if we're going to
embrace transgenderism we need to
support drag shows there's even a
difference between transgenderism and a
drag show transgenderism is when a
confused man thinks that he's a woman a
drag show is when a deviant man knows
that he's not a woman but thinks it'll
be kind of funny to dress up like one
and put on a bawdy sexual performance
those are totally different things and
then this drag queen he says what
we're basically strippers why are you
why are you taking your kids to the
stripper shows what have we done we
haven't done it all the defining feature
of a drag queen is putting on
sex shows sexual shows
in nightclubs for adults
the difference between a drag queen and
a stripper well other than the
anatomical differences
is that a stripper puts on a sexual show
and a drag queen puts on a funny sexual
show
a drag show is just
basically a stripper burlesque show with
more jokes and humor
right and you have the drag queen and
the drag queens are really outrageous
and that's why when they do the parades
up and down new york they're telling
jokes and doing all sorts of
comedy but it's that's it it's just kind
of a funny funnier sex show
you wouldn't take your kid to a strip
club
why would you take your kid to a and you
wouldn't take your kid even to a late
night raunchy comedy show
why would you take your kid to both of
them at the same time
with a lot of sexual confusion added on
in addition
because we've we it's because we have
lost our minds on indulgence i'm not
surprised that the libs are pushing this
stuff the libs have always had an
interest in sexualizing well everybody
and especially kids they've been writing
about this for 100 years wilhelm reich
going back to the the early 20th century
this leftist intellectual said that the
problem
all of the problems in the world war
disease everything in between they're
caused by a lack of orgasms not joking
and he said that he had invented an
orgone accumulator to to collect the the
essence of of life and the essence of
the world the organs floating around
this was mocked in the pop culture as an
orgasmatron and lots of intellectuals on
the left had it norman mailer had it jd
salinger had it bernie sanders wrote
about this kind of stuff and how we need
to sexualize kids he wrote about it in
the 1960s in essays in the vermont
freeman you can still read them
they've been i get why the libs are
pushing this stuff it's part of their
their campaign to upend society in the
words of marx ruthlessly criticize
everything that exists my only issue
here is why i'm being so harsh on the
conservatives here is what have you been
doing they've been telling you what they
want to do for 50 to 100 years now
they've been doing it successfully and
then what do you do you say well you
know it's not my place if someone wants
to put on a drag show for children
that's a blessing of liberty and that's
it's not my place to ever have a point
of view about that well what
the libs don't think that the
conservatives didn't think that until
five minutes ago i don't i'm not even
sure you really think that
i just think you've just been deluded
or you're so beaten down by the leftist
advances in the culture
that you don't you don't have the
hutzpah to go out and fight come on push
back and fight guys
you know the other aspect of the drag
queens that's important here is
the transgender person
wants to pretend that he's really the
woman it's a it's a realistic
performance of a woman the essence of a
drag show is that it's a very
unrealistic performance it this
difference between realism and
unrealism is at the heart of it there
was a
tick tock that went viral the other day
of some confused woman describing not
just her transgenderism but her neo
pronouns and specifically why she uses
them
so neopronouns are any set of pronouns
that aren't officially recognized in the
language that you use someone might use
neopronouns because
officially recognized pronouns might
give them dysphoria or using
neos could give someone gender euphoria
i use them because they give me euphoria
because i really enjoy confusing people
with my gender identity
which sounds kind of weird but it gives
me euphoria so whatever
i really like using they them and fair
in conversation like when i'm talking
and i really like using bon bon self uh
like if i'm texting someone or
i guess just on the internet
um that's that's the way i like using
them
so an example of faith fair pronouns
could be
i really like fair jacket today it's
their favorite color
they like the color purple and an
example of bun bun self pronouns could
be
bunched up on my for you page today bond
really likes using neo pronouns
bun really gets a kick out of this
and bun would prefer if you would refer
to bun by bun self's preferred bun buns
pronouns that's true it does not give me
euphoria it gives me bemusement but it
doesn't give me euphoria
euphoria is the key word there i'm so
glad this gal gets it this gal i don't
think she intended to point this out but
she says the opposite of dysphoria is
euphoria in the transgender ideology
dysphoria means this
unrealistic view of your own body that
is a negative view of your own body
but euphoria as it is used in modern
life is an unrealistic feeling of
happiness euphoria is what you get when
you shoot up heroin
that's the it's the feeling that you get
you're not you're not really happy
you're not really thriving or
flourishing but it's the feeling that
you get
and
this this gal seems to suggest that
those are the only two ways to live in
this dysphoria or this euphoria how
about you live in real life how about
real life with real happiness grounded
on real things that is entirely missing
from the conversation
the extreme
the extreme unrealism of what the left
is pushing especially when we're talking
about the sex stuff is a big problem and
i i feel for this girl this girl
who says you know refer to me as bun bun
self and
fairy pronouns and whatever all these
pronouns that are even beyond the 57
usual ones that we get these days
this girl is
has been raised at a time
of such surreality where life is not
lived primarily in the real world but is
lived in the virtual world it's
increasingly going to be lived in the
metaverse it's lived on social media
it's lived with a focus only on oneself
it's lived with a focus on how i feel
not with a care to other people's pain
or objective reality but only a care for
one's own pleasure
a a culture of narcissism
and so it's no surprise that she says
this gives me euphoria what a weird
thing to say she doesn't say this makes
me happy or this is a good thing to do
she says it gives me euphoria
it's like when people it's when people
describe themselves as a bag of
chemicals they say gosh i got such an
adrenaline rush
they don't say boy i was excited wow
that thrilled me no they say i got an
adrenaline rush because you're just
thinking of yourself as a big bag of
chemicals that just reacts to different
stimuli and when the stimuli poke you
and make you feel good on the inside
then you want more of that that gives
you euphoria and when they make you feel
bad you want less of that with no care
to objective reality or to discipline or
to some temporary pain that might
strengthen someone over time something
tells me that these people who are just
focused entirely on themselves and their
own
low base pleasures something tells me
they don't have a great relationship
with their parents
just i'm not saying it's 100 of the time
but usually when you see people dancing
around talking about bun bun self and
all you know all sorts of mutilations on
them and they're screaming and they're
yelling and they're protesting outside
of the supreme court justice's houses
you look at that you say huh
something tells me you don't have a
great relationship with dad
it's a little harsh to say
but
999 times out of a thousand that is
going to be
the case
so this is why this is one this is a
problem that you've got to solve
first
before we figure out the debt and the
deficit before we figure out um
immigration before we figure out the tax
rates and the and the way that we can
kind of fix some of the institutions and
the energy policy before you can figure
out
higher level political issues
if you've got a country
where your family has completely broken
down
you're not going to solve any of those
political problems because the family is
the basic political institution daily
wire just did an analysis of new census
data
according to this analysis there are a
lot lots of parts of this country
where most people do not grow up with
two parents puerto rico
just kind of america kind of kind of
sort of part of america
only 38
of puerto rican children live with two
parents
washington dc only 48
of
dc residents
children live with two parents
mississippi louisiana new mexico
it's a little higher it's above the 50
threshold but not much 55
57 according to census data
you you can't have a flourishing country
that way that is going to create just
think about it just think about
something that happened in your
childhood whether you grew up with two
parents or one parent or no parents or
however you grew up think about one
thing that happened even if you grew up
in the greatest household ever
leave it to beaver father knows best
donna reed household
did something happen in your childhood
that kind of messed you up a little bit
did i don't know
daddy and mommy fought a little bit too
much or
i don't know daddy traveled too much or
there was some there was some big fight
that broke out or even in your extended
family and so and so didn't talk to
uncle
what's his face and did something happen
when you were a kid daddy yelled at you
one time okay
think about that that relatively minor
experience of childhood trauma
and now have it be that your parents
just don't care about you and they don't
care about you enough to try to to
focus on your upbringing and daddy
disappears for
for huge stretches of time if he's there
at all and or maybe mommy doesn't really
care about maybe maybe mommy just leaves
daddy and you know she puts the kids
kind of second or third if she's
thinking about them at all and you know
look they're just going to focus on them
they're going to live their best life
okay and frankly it'll be better for the
kids if mommy and daddy are are happy
quote unquote
pursuing their own selfish desires you
can't
if if one incident at the dinner table
is going to kind of mess you up as a kid
no matter how
nice your upbringing was
imagine you're living in a society where
most
kids don't live with both of their
parents
maybe they get to maybe they get to see
both their parents sometime i don't
maybe
think about how much that's going to
mess up all of those kids think about
how much that's going to mess up society
you know it's not not every political
issue comes down to some textbook
explanation when and some formal
academic debate
and frankly more of of what shapes our
politics is that ronald reagan said
politics begins around the dinner table
what happens when there's no dinner
table what happens when mommy and daddy
just aren't home and you're sitting at
home on a snack tray alone watching tv
well then that dinner table that's going
to be your politics and especially when
the tv that's that's being pumped into
you or the streaming now
is promoting radical woke propaganda
especially when you're the only solid
relationship that the kids have is going
to be with their teacher in a public
school there are great public school
teachers but there's a lot of crap that
goes on in the public schools too or
their only relationship is with some
movie star on tv or their only
relationship is some parasocial
relationship on social media pushing
crazy woke stuff that's a major major
political problem that's not enough to
say you do you figure it out well i'm
just going to focus on no we we need to
structure our society in such a way that
it's better for those kids for society
as a whole if we don't do that
we're just conceding the culture to the
radicals we've done that for 50 years
it's led us to this madness maybe it's
time to try a new strategy i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bourie supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show